hey 42 here one of the defining images
of the Modern Age was the moment when
man first set foot on the moon
on the 20th of July 1969 whilst the
world crowded around transistor radios
and those TV sets of the funny wooden
trim Neil Armstrong took one small step
for a man in what was the culmination of
years of experimentation and Endeavor
this was the crowning glory of the
post-war American dream and proved that
there is nothing the United States
couldn't do
they had finally conquered space just as
they had helped conquer the ultimate
Evil of Adolf Hitler 25 years earlier
but what most of those cheering the
brave boys of Apollo 11 didn't know was
just how closely connected these two
world-shaping events really were
yeah
sure the free astronauts in the
spacecraft in 1969 were as American as a
bald eagle shopping in Walmart
however many of those who made that
Journey possible weren't Americans but
Germans and not just any Germans the
really really naughty kind Nazis
[Applause]
the truth is that the American Space
Program of the 50s and 60s was overseen
by scientist technicians and Engineers
with an involuntary right arm-raising
disease who'd been smuggled out of
Germany after the war as part of the
most audacious and controversial Talent
grab in history codenamed Operation
Paperclip it saw more than 1600 of the
third reich's top scientific Minds avoid
trial in Europe to instead be spirited
across the Atlantic to apply their
expertise to areas like synthetic fuels
communication systems and Aeronautics
the US Army was especially Keen to make
use of the men who had knowledge of
rockets the very same Rockets originally
designed to rain down fiery death on
America and her allies
this car drove Elite scientist was
headed by Nazi rocket engineer Werner
Von Braun and he was so influential to
America's success in reaching the stars
that he became known as Dr space and was
eventually enshrined in America's
national Aviation Hall of Fame with the
help of his loyal band of big brained
former fascists he ignited America's
efforts to conquer outer space and his
controversial Legacy would forever be
entwined with man's Destiny beyond the
stars
storyblocks is an incredibly vast stock
library with over a million high quality
4K and HD footage templates music sound
effects images and so much more the best
part they offer unlimited downloads of
royalty-free professional content for
one predictable subscription cost say
goodbye to expensive pay-per-clip
pricing plus you can choose a monthly or
annual plan with no hidden extra fees I
absolutely love using storyblocks for
this channel because anything I download
with storyblocks is 100 royalty free
forever with no restrictions on where
you can distribute your finished
projects it just gives me so much peace
of mind and if you're like me and you
use Adobe Creative Cloud you can save a
ton of time by using the storyblocks
plugin this allows you to access the
entire storyblocks library right inside
Premiere Pro and after effects also you
can choose from thousands of pre-made
professional templates for your favorite
editing program including After Effects
Premiere Pro and apple motion this takes
your video to the next level and speeds
up your creative workflow by letting you
easily add Motion Graphics title
animations overlays and Logo reveals to
supercharge the production value of your
videos to get started with unlimited
stock media downloads at one set price
head to storyblocks.com
42 or click the link in the description
and a big thanks to storyblocks for
sponsoring this video fonbrom was
obsessed with space from the age of 13
when his mother bought him a telescope
but it wasn't just what he saw in the
night sky that fed his imagination
Germany in the 1920s was the place to be
if you had any interest in rocket
technology Fitz Von Opel to the Opel car
company was known by the rather
brilliant nickname of Rocket Fritz and
he gave public demonstrations in which
he drove cars and planes he'd fitted
with rockets
ah I sure do miss those good old days
when health and safety hadn't been
invented yet naturally this Drew huge
crowds young Werner amongst them and
when his ambitious young guys fixated
upon the site of a crazy German man
driving inside a fireball of certain
death
he just knew that he had to do the same
one of the most enthusiastic members of
this little group was this 18 year old
boy destined to become one of the Giants
of the American Space Program Werner Von
Braun
now at 16 most boys are preoccupied
trying to figure out how females
function but not from Braun he was busy
strapping fireworks to a toy wagon he
then climbed inside and lit the Rockets
causing the jerry-rigged vehicle to
barrel down the streets of Berlin before
spectacularly blowing up
was lucky to walk away of his life and
was promptly arrested though he was let
off with a warning shortly afterwards
rocket Fritz sounding suspiciously like
a kitchen appliance from the 60s had lit
the fuse on Fon bronze passion for space
travel but this food processor called
rocket scientist wasn't from bronze only
inspiration because in 1930 he attended
a lecture by August Pickard
Picard had invented a pressurized cabin
which when fitted to a hydrogen balloon
allowed him to travel to Earth's upper
atmosphere by the way if that surname
sounds familiar it's probably because
Patrick Stewart's character in Star Trek
was named after him the show's writers
were inspired by August's ability to go
where no man has gone before in a
balloon
in 1930 Von Braun attended University in
Berlin where he immediately signed up to
the space flight Society unlike most
student societies which are just an
excuse to insert beer tubes into the
most inappropriate holes the space
flight Society saw a group of Rocket
Fanatics conducting some of the first
ever experiments with liquid-fueled
rocket engines but Rockets weren't the
only thing on the rise in Germany in the
1930s and thus a decade war on the
country gradually fell under the
malevolent spell of Adolf Hitler
straight out of University Verna Von
Braun founded his own rocket development
business before going to work for the
military on prototypes guided missiles
becoming technical director of an army
Research Center on an island just off
the northern coast of Germany why does
everything seedy have to happen on an
island in 1937 with the Nazis now in
full control Farm Braun became a party
member and eventually a major in the SS
he would later claim he did so purely so
he could continue his research and that
he was never ever involved with any
political activity which is like saying
so yeah basically I didn't see all the
atrocities because I was busy playing
with Lego in a cupboard for several
years
when the second world war broke out that
need for more effective weapons became
immediately apparent and the military
realized Von Braun's Rockets had the
potential to swing the conflict in their
favor continuing his research to the
fatherland's very own rocket man came up
with the world's first long-range guided
ballistic missile the V2 or to give it
its full title for girl pong swatha the
Vengeance weapon designing these Rockets
took the genius of fonbron and his team
of scientists but building them required
the blood and sweat of many others
almost 1.7 million people were sent to
Nazi concentration camps during the
course of the war and most were used as
slave labor in one form or another
including the building of armaments for
the very regime that had imprisoned them
VT Rockets were made in the giant
Middleburg Factory constructed
underground so it would be safe from
Allied bombs conditions there were
utterly inhumane with inmates from the
nearby middle bowdora concentration camp
quite literally worked to death
when the V2s were finally Unleashed in
late 1944 an estimated 9 000 Allied
soldiers and civilians were killed but
the tragic irony is that that figure is
substantially lower than the 12 000 who
lost their lives building them in the
first place
in April 1945 as the war Drew to a close
from Braun and over 400 other scientists
were moved to a secure location where
they were guarded by an elite unit to
keep them from being captured by the
allies
as it became evident that World War II
was going to be one of those where the
bad guys lose Hitler sent orders that
everyone involved with the development
of rockets should be gassed so their
knowledge didn't fall into enemy hands
but words somehow got through to Von
Braun and for some reason he didn't like
the sound of that plan at all so he came
up with one of his own to get himself
and his fellow scientists the hell out
of their post haste
commandeering a train they escaped into
the mountains of Southern Germany and
over the border into Austria Werner and
his brother Magnus subsequently
surrendered to American forces in a
rather unconventional fashion
with Magnus cycling out to find the
nearest armor unit with a white bed
sheet tied to his handlebars so they
knew he came in peace
whilst it's fair to say that Hitler had
some seriously out there ideas in fact
he was kind of famous for them he was
bang on the money when it came to
thinking the Allies were Keen to get
their hands on Nazi rocket Pioneers in
fact the Allies were so Keen to do so
that they dedicated an entire secret
intelligent program of 2 000 people to
it
this was Operation Paperclip so called
because when working their way through
the mountains of files of potential
scientists to steal office buds in the
Army's ordinance Corps would attach a
paperclip to those who were of
particular interest they identified over
5 000 targets and the ominously named
enemy Personnel exploitation section was
created in order to interrogate them
this unit worked in a detention center
with the code name now are you ready for
this because it's really really badass
Dustbin yeah
the Dustbin was housed in kransberg
Castle near Frankfurt this Castle had
been earmarked to be Hitler's main
military HQ and hidden deep beneath the
Earth beneath the imposing medieval
ramparts was an elaborate Warren of
concrete bunkers having been thoroughly
debriefed from Braun and more than 130
of his team were moved to the United
States and their new home a Fort Bliss
in El Paso Texas
Fort Bliss is a massive U.S army base
that covers some 1700 square miles and
during the second world war it was used
to train anti-aircraft Gunners and hold
prisoners of war the conditions the pows
had found themselves in were too
different to those in which the
scientists were bedded down in now
sleeping in sparse huts and being fed
meager rations
still it was preferable to the
alternative Hitler had in mind for them
back home in the Fatherland
fonbron and his comrades were soon put
to work refurbishing V2 rocket that had
been salvaged in Germany and after five
years in Texas this party of propulsion
loving professors were moved to another
base in Alabama where they worked on
something even bigger the rockets that
were to be used for the first ever
nuclear ballistic missile tests
but as we all know inside every Nazi
scientist is a little boy trying to get
out and no matter how many missiles he
designed from Braun still yearned to
send men into space just as he had as an
astronomy obsessed adolescent
as fate would have it werner's lifelong
dream was now part of the very Zeitgeist
of the country that he lived in this was
1950s America and just like in Toy Story
when Buzz replaced Woody so the Cowboys
who'd been idolized for decades were
being replaced by characters from space
movies and sci-fi comics
Von Braun began to write about his
theories of Rocket trips to the moon and
orbital space stations articles which
were published not in Dusty science
journals but in newspapers and National
magazines he even found himself working
with Waltz Disney acting as technical
director to free Disney films about
space exploration
but behind all this publicity and
fantasy was the reality of the space
race between the United States and the
Soviet Union with each superpower
desperate to outdo the other in a bid to
gain strategic control of the great
black Battleground outside Earth's
atmosphere
in 1957 the Soviets launched the first
ever satellite Sputnik 1 into orbit and
the U.S fearful of falling behind the
Communist curve responded by creating
the National Aeronautics and Space
Administration better known as NASA
which at least in the beginning was
dedicated to one thing getting into
space real quick and who is at the top
of the government's professional
spaceship flinger list well that's right
the man who put the SS into the United
States
Verna Thon Bron he was made director of
NASA's Marshall space flight center in
his appointment proved to be a crucial
turning point that would lead to the
Americans putting a man on the moon less
than a decade later
Tom Braun and his team had been working
on rockets that could carry a spacecraft
into orbit they were named the Saturn
series and they were eventually used in
the Apollo space program throughout the
1960s Saturn V launched the Apollo 11
mission to the moon and in culmination
of his life's work Von Braun was right
there in London's control in the Kennedy
Space Center he wasn't the only ex-nazi
in attendance either the director of the
Kennedy Space Center was Kurt debus an
old colleague of Von Braun from his days
building V2 rockets for the Reich TheBus
had also come to America as one of 1600
Nazi scientists secretly recruited as
part of Operation Paperclip
for their roles in helping an American
astronaut set force on the moon before
any other both Von Braun and debus were
awarded to the NASA distinguished
service medal one of the highest
accolades a NASA employee can earn
it's one of the great twists of Fate
that many of the men who played a role
in one of the darkest chapters in our
history then made a lasting contribution
to one of the most hopeful maybe it was
always fated to be that way after all is
it just a coincidence that NASA and Nazi
are only two letters different
well yes yes it is obviously still the
scientists who were covertly brought to
the USA after the war helped their
adopted country to win the space race
and the patents and Innovative
Technologies they created would go on to
be worth 10 billion dollars
over the years they Rose to the top
positions of some of the most important
and influential government agencies in
the world
truly a case of keep your friends close
but your enemies closer thanks for
watching